scambio sorpreso non ci facciamo lavoro
di pack up rischiano di vedere qual è la
sorpresa più bella che operava
soprattutto stile ma sarà tutto
praticamente noi ci ruota è la ruota
deciderà quale multipass potremmo ad
aprire però nella ruota c'è anche lo
scambio di sorprese e anche bendati
prima altre volte pescare le uova da
bendati alla fine del video dovrebbe
votare chi vince in base alle sorprese
che vi sono ovviamente più di tutti
quindi mi raccomando però te il video
fino alla fine facesse sapere qual è il
nuovo che mi è piaciuto più di tutti
perché vogliono stare il cioccolato più
buono che dividevo assaggiare tutti
vediamo chi inizia a farmi cesar si fa
di successo fu fatto allora siccome la
ruota lo abbiamo ordinato ma non c'è
ancora arrivata andremo a usare la route
digitale girarle vediamo che uomo mi
capita bene vediamo ora vitale quale
uovo capita no ma non ce l'abbiamo un
altro giro e lo sfogo tron è questo e
molto altro di ognuno limitiamo a questo
spread che abbiamo dentro questo nuovo è
un po mangiucchiato e lo sapete perché
perché vitale mi ha nascosto le uova mi
ha fatto uno scherzo
benino dopo questo figlio andato non
aver subito in cui vi nascondo le uova e
dà la colpa a merlino e benefit questa
qui quest'aquila mandato berlino non
sono andate in mezzo anche la quale un
po patrol
vediamo vediamo che cagnolino ci capita
speriamo un cagnolino questo mini a
berlino la facciamo diventare
hanno cambiato il fiocchetto meno male
perché in genere sarà quello il filo ed
era impossibile da aprire in aria buona
[Musica]
vediamo un po la nostra sorpresa ma no
quel bambino a herat 2 giu minute armata
organico come il nostro pezzo
saluti dal voto che carino
montiamo da qua verso cappellino vediamo
un po mezzo fa da montare che campo per
ora si gira la testa e basta che poi
metterlo gli speaker quindi forse erano
su questi due devono capitare indicato
ne pensate di questo sorprende molto
grinder vedo dove per ogni sorpreso a
date un voto da 1 a 10 nei commenti dopo
le possiamo vedere a berlino e vediamo
quale gli piace più di tutte colpa
allora over zio tom di modica magari poi
ci scambiamo st scrive cama magari dove
vediamo che tu pacchetto calcio
dobbiamo dire poi di chi lo stesso
capito un bel peluche sinistra un
gattino occhiale gare o un credito per
berlino è qui che fa da aiutante che
cosa c'è 21 mag grande questo abbiamo la
prima privato per la infatti tutti
famiglie proprio crudi il ballerino
tutti i miei comitale no finora questa è
la mia sorpresa ho preferito mi piace
più del cammino secondo round vediamo
chi gira prima carta come prima
[Musica]
[Applauso]
quello che volevo abitava perché evitare
donna cioccolato fondente alle nocciole
di nagoya non basta con lo slang
all'interno di fatto anche soffrire
frutta mente perché voglio vedere come
ha fatto lo slime centro è ben felice
che rimbalza si può dirla si street si
ricompone va bene eccolo qua d'italia
d'ore questo cioccolato infatti forse è
tutto dorato dentro
ha scelto bene sono all'interno ce l'ha
fatta
[Applauso]
poi ognuno è piccolissima vediamo ecco
qua la sorpresa è piccolissima vediamo
che cos'è il cioccolato per uno
benissimo che cosa è un bracciale a una
collina di ti amo non riesco a vederlo
allora mi sembra una collanina che un
bracciale meno male capitato a me allora
voglio al quadrifoglio con il foglio
carina questa sorpresa
ora me la metto subito dopo berlino sta
pensando mamma e poi dove lo daranno più
nuovo a navi e collina che carina
all'uovo di pasqua slide rosso
oltre a questo c'è ancora una cella che
si tira si parli della mattinata
dovrebbe già aprile con il piccolo modo
riesce se lo prendi tu
ecco qua l'uomo così non abbiamo che
sarà molto morbido che conosciamo più
cioccolato testo anch'io la saggia letto
eccolo qua
e meno male alcolismo vediamo come come
siamo adesso lo apriamo scopriamo di
adottare febbre vescovo panne un modello
a rimbalzare allunga è mio
carino molto carino rapido come slide
sarebbe stata una pasta un po dura
invece è abbastanza me lo aspettavo un
po più butters line vivo però in realtà
è bello bello morbidoso bene che tu hai
vinto lo slam
rimbalza veramente noi facciamo una
pallina o no se lo presta preferite tra
questo slam e la collanina vota per i
commenti
e a chi inizia per dare questo impegno
certo forse tanto che al tavolo tanto 83
girando girato veloce scambio sorpreso
contento perché volevo il pupazzo e
parabita le li mettiamo la collanina
gravitelli tiamina ecco qua
vediamo come esista carinaro timer
italiani a urbino nonché a me giriamo
per operato ma non tutti purtroppo è già
capitato quindi dobbiamo originare una
base riuscire scambi sorprese nuovamente
i bozzetti che fa questo e questo
piccolo piccolo e sono gli effetti del
cuore
che carino non vede l'ora di vedere che
succede dentro questo crimini come
questo del gruppo fa già giornata così
me lo mangio tutto intero capitale
girerà nuovamente la ruota perché le
uova sono pari quindi le apriamo in
contemporanea quindi oltre allo scambio
poi rifiutato con originato dai romani
attaccherà la ruota digitale vediamo
vediamo
scambiamo di nuovo un filo più grandi di
noi
inter e sorprese piccolissima diamo la
sorpresina piccola piccola e andiamo
piccolissimi quindi niente di che questa
sorpresa insomma telo carino e settima
la sorpresa alle formiche
ma adesso cosa c'è nulla sorpreso il
bambino va bene sono stato al centro di
un bambino non è affatto passata
cioccolato è carino vero e morbido ai
servizi affatto sorpreso per il casino
perché essendo unicorno malore gorno o
il quale preferite la dell'unicorno gli
adesivi degli effetti che non ricordo
propri sporchi anche per ultimo lo
vediamo chi inizia con riso
lo faccio io ritiro io pagina strana ma
che avete capito acerba della carta poi
dopo le scambiamo i gattini disegnabile
lo spero che ci sia qualcosa di caldo
dorati ho fatto mio il vino subito
questa casa nostra nazione tutto
studiosa perché non fa questo pregio
possa essere dentro
[Musica]
e accaduto chiare fatecelo cioccolato
che cos'è cliche est vediamo un po
quartiere tanti fantastici e speakers
quasi fatto gli stickers li puoi
scegliere i tiri fuori e le sceglie
tutti quelli che vuoi
eccoli rullo di stickers sbaglio erano
anche questa sorpresa c'erano anche
negli utenti questa come quello che ho
tagliato io ti ricordi ero così sorpreso
mi aspettavo un pochino di più
vediamo ora nel mio cosa c'è a nuovo
caffarel vedete che si sono tanti gatti
v della carta
speriamo che ci sia qualcosa riguardo
[Musica]
[Applauso]
putroppo è vero ma vediamo un po molto
sentirà buono stato pezzo questo
buonissimo questo cioccolato come molle
a piccole bolle che ci sono ed adattata
per sempre di screen e divertenti ieri
questo molto per far tornare gli attori
ha una rosa blu e quindi carino ma
niente di che quale sorpresa preferite
tra le molle e gli adesivi dal gol
le molle yo yo forte gli adesivi della
lolla anche se mi aspettavo un po di più
vediamo aree protette sorprende allora o
round abramo luogo mario kart è il nuovo
cucciolo orti temi tra cui c'è un
cucciolo capiti quello perché scapito
quello allora giriamola volta che la
compone il tasso è fa kart ha portato
vantaggi anche perché allora facciamo
piano lo facciamo superveloce scoperto
oppure come girare veloce la roma
[Musica]
super mario kart quindi vitale ma quello
di mario cal il popolo dei cuccioli che
sono più o partirà per cento e neanche
averlo capito che si può fare lo stesso
lotto proceduti memova presentiamo la
sorpresa più bella
vediamo un po nell'uomo ma al loro
bisogno della ford è già scritto c'era
l'altra vitale piace un sacco ai varchi
di viaggio non è quindi macchina non è
stato diverso
togliamo prima l'uomo apriamo
dobbiamo allora mettiamo subito le
marmitte ma dobbiamo mettere nemmeno
lante facile da montare ma erano anche
mi sono così basta ecco qui ero al
contrario quindi dobbiamo montare le
marmitte di qua evitare vorrei che
meglio buttarle volante
[Applauso]
eccolo qui l'abbiamo messa di papa
bellissimo devo dire che questo è
veramente fatto bene
anche mario è fatto su per bene fai
vedere il foglietto
ma vediamo chi altro c'era c'era luigi
il funghetto solo principe dove in
carrozza dove nuovo start e poi abbiamo
anche di jesi vissuto così non ho capito
ma da una delle marmitte come li
mettiamo
l'ultimo uovo io spero che mi capiti
questo cagnolino paolo copertina
guardate quanto assomiglia a merlino
allo stesso colore agli occhi azzurri e
le orecchie basse sono migliori anche
gli altri sono carinissimi quindi
vediamo un po
[Musica]
a fronte di lui sembravano i money
orecchie droghe tirati lupo è
carinissimo vediamo che torino ha quindi
lunghi color crema il collarino
costitutiva e gli occhietti azzurro ma è
bellissimo
quindi che sorpresa vince tra questi due
io sono indecisa sono tutti e due
bellissime però servi canterino perché
forte sovraccarico o anche nonno gardo
di orari vediamo tutte le sorprese
sciogliamo un vincitore allora
ricapitoliamo tutte le sorprese lo slime
ogata panda qua non mi far proprio
mercato da attori avviarle di kurt degli
attacchi otti poi abbiamo il cru di
maialino ecco qua poi abbiamo il
cucciolotto cartellino poi in varie
carte a cui dobbiamo ancora mettere gli
stickers poi inviato da subito le loro
patron e poi le molle allora cura della
pelle
l'anello del giorno ricorda il
quadrifoglio nelle sedi
tutti aver visto indeciso tra il
maialino il cagnolino o perché sono sti
due stupendi ma c'è un cagnolino è
secondo voi qual è la sorpresa più bella
tra queste mutate me i commenti boxing
hall per soprattutto col cioccolato
possibilità che s'è rivolto a tutti è la
rovina savoca 4 cartellino su cui
cliccare per vedere i nostri altri video
cliccate su quella che preferite
buona visione